G7 leaders will get a surprise visit
from Ukrainian president zielinski this
weekend he is pushing other countries to
provide still more weapons ahead of a
long-awaited Ukrainian counter-offensive
against Russian forces and just a short
time ago President Biden met with other
G7 leaders at the summit where new
sanctions against Russia are expected to
be unveiled Elizabeth Palmer is in
Hiroshima Japan where the meetings are
taking place it's all the actions there
Liz good morning
good morning yes all the leaders are now
here safely and the conference
officially got underway today in the
rain with ceremonies in one of Japan's
most famous and also moving historical
sites
prime minister fumio kishida and his
wife greeted the president and Dr Biden
at Japan's peace part and then the
leaders of the G7 Nations laid wreaths
at the memorial to the victims of the
first use of atomic weapons the U.S
bombing of Hiroshima during World War II
the real work of the summit began over
lunch as the leaders turned to a packed
agenda with support for Ukraine at the
top of the list and then the news broke
that President Vladimir zielinski would
travel to Hiroshima in person his
appearance will underline Vladimir
Putin's recent threats to use nuclear
weapons in Ukraine and bolster
zelenski's appeal for more Western
backup National Security Council
coordinator for strategic Communications
John Kirby says the timing is critical
ukrainians have said they want to go on
the offense we all have to make sure
that they have all the support that they
need to do so
and Europe are already working to send
f-16s to Ukraine in spite of fears that
the American-made fighter jets May
escalate the conflict the u.s's leading
efforts to choke off the money and
Equipment flowing to Russia which it
depends on to finance the war
that's going to mean some new sanctions
but also serious measures to close
loopholes on those already in place
now president zielinski was always
invited to address this conference by
video the fact that he's showing up in
person is uh Sensational of course but
it's also going to Eclipse some of the
other items that should have been high
on the agenda here and that includes
climate change and also how the world
faces the threat security threat posed
by China okay
got it Elizabeth Palmer at the G7 Summit
we thank you